seechurn sq juste à côté de
severodonetsk est frappée en permanence
par les bombardements l'immense majorité
des habitants à quitter les lieux mais
certains s'accrochent désespérément à
leur ville de toujours
guy nous ne voulons pas aller quelque
part où nous n'aurons plus notre propre
toit il y a beaucoup de gens dans notre
ville qui ne sont pas partis parce
qu'ils ont travaillé pour avoir leur
propre appartement toute leur vie
ici nous sommes chez nous c'est tout ce
que nous savons nous avons grandi ici ou
devrions nous aller et nous n'avons pas
d'argent non plus pour un séjour plus
long ailleurs
à barghout à quelques dizaines de
kilomètres du front les services
d'urgence tentent de convaincre cette
habitante de partir mais elle se refuse
à quitter sa ville la peur des
bombardements tout proche est trop forte
vous savez je suis malade je ne veux pas
être un poids pour les autres et aller
d'un endroit à l'autre
non ce n'est pas ce que je veux
[Musique]
hier le ministre de la défense russe a
revendiqué la conquête des quartiers
résidentiels de severodonetsk le
président ukrainien a salué la
résistance héroïque de ses troupes dans
le donbass objectif affiché par le
kremlin